as 2020 heads into his last few months
netflix's content catalog is turning
over once again
here's a selection of the very best
movies television shows
and everything in between coming to
netflix in november 2020
as well as the titles that sadly will be
leaving the platform
if you're looking for a laugh netflix
has you covered this november with a few
old favorites that will always make you
chuckle
if you've never seen easy a which marked
the first starring role for future
academy award winner emma stone
now's the time with the supporting cast
that includes stanley tucci
lisa kudrow patricia clarkson and more
the movie is a pure delight and stone is
effortlessly charming in it
are you ready for the grand finale yeah
what
yeah meanwhile if you're looking for a
cable to go with your comedy
ocean's 11 will do the trick steven
soderbergh's remake of the classic
rapbackhouse movie of the same name
comes with his own superstar cast and
follows george clooney brad pitt
matt damon don cheadle julia roberts and
the late carl reiner's characters as
they along with several of their friends
tried to rob multiple casinos in las
vegas we're just supposed to walk out of
there with 150 million dollars in cash
yeah oh however if you just want pure
silliness in november 2020
you'll definitely want to queue up yes
man the jim carrey led comedy where the
comedian's character must say yes to
everything that's asked of him
you can stream all three of these movies
starting november 1st
yes yes yes since the spooky season will
officially be over in november 2020
netflix isn't offering horror fans many
scares next month
that said though there are two scary
movies coming your way that you won't
want to miss
on november 1st netflix is adding the
eli roth directed horror flick
knock knock starring keanu reeves reeve
stars as a married man who finds himself
in the middle of a dangerous situation
after spending the night with two women
who claim to be stranded
it doesn't take long for his dalliance
to come back to haunt him when the women
are revealed to be more than they
originally seemed
then on november 12th horror devotees
have 2008's prom night to look forward
to
loosely based on the 1980 film starring
jamie lee curtis the 2008 feature
centers around donna
a traumatized teen who witnessed her
teacher violently slay her entire family
after he became obsessed with her three
years later he escaped from prison just
in time to ruin donna senior prom
with another killing spree november 2020
selection of dramas on netflix is packed
with star-studded movies starring
michael b
jordan joseph gordon-levitt and amy
adams whether you're looking to catch up
on past hits or check out something
entirely new there truly is something
for every drama lover on netflix next
month the streamer is kicking things off
with 2016 snowden which arrives on
november 1st
directed by oliver stone the film
dramatizes the life of edward snowden
as he trades in a job within the
intelligence community to become a
whistleblowing fugitive
then on november 12th movie fans can
revisit foodvale station
the first feature-length film helmed by
black panther director ryan coogler
the heartbreaking film is based on a
true story and stars michael b
jordan as oscar grant a young black man
who was killed during an encounter with
police
just a few days later on november 16th
viewers can stream another acclaimed
drama movie based on a true story
2016's loving starring joel edgerton and
ruth nager
as richard and mildred loving the couple
who successfully challenged state laws
that banned interracial marriages
nager's incredible performance in loving
earned her a best actress nomination
at the 2017 oscars finally on november
24th
the long-awaited hillbilly elegy arrives
on netflix based on jd vance's
best-selling memoir of the same name the
film focuses on a struggling
working-class family
in the appalachia region of the united
states and their yale graduate son who
was forced to return to his dying
hometown
to help his family the movie's cast is
headed up by the heavy-hitting duo of
amy adams and glenn close
which may make this one appealing
whether you've read the book before or
not
everyone in this world is one of three
kinds good terminator
a bad terminator and neutral
netflix is bringing a cornucopia of
action to its digital shelves in
november 2020.
for anyone still reeling from the end of
season two cobra kai fans will be
thrilled to learn that there's another
shot of miyagi dough
coming to their device of choice this
1994 follow-up to the original karate
kid trilogy
sees mr miyagi taking on a new student
julie played by hilary swank
it was a simpler time back when movies
about hillary swank learning how to
fight didn't end with clint eastwood
taking her off life support
additionally the 2018 mark wahlberg
starring action thriller mile 22
brought to you by director peter berg
the guy behind hancock and battleship
drops on the streaming service on
november 1st netflix is also offering to
subscribers a pair of dystopian flicks
next month
a clockwork orange stanley kubrick's
owed to milk and long johns will be
available to stream beginning november
1st
that was a real kick and good for laughs
and lashings of the old
ultra violent looking for a double
feature try pairing a clockwork orange
with v for vendetta
which you can queue up starting on
november 15th
ready to learn something new netflix has
a variety of documentaries heading to
his library in november 2020
all designed to help you become more
informed about current events music
and the latest true crime mystery this
month kicks off on november 5th with
carmel who killed maria mata
the new ducky series dives into the
mystery surrounding the death of maria
marta garcia belsunce who's at the
center of a case that sparked an outcry
in argentina
netflix then switches things up with the
timely who's streets on november 16th
the powerful dark chronicles of ferguson
uprising and how the death of 18 year
old michael brown
sparked a movement that forced america
to begin to reckon with his legacy of
racial injustice
if you're in search of a musical
documentary the streamer has you covered
on that front too
on november 23rd singer sean mendes is
giving fans unprecedented access to his
world tour
and private life in the intimate sean
mendes in wonder
obviously the stand-up comedy landscape
has been a little bear in recent months
as a result there haven't been a ton of
new comedy specials to watch
on netflix in october 2020 the closest
that we got was bird christian's the
cabin
a dark youth series about comics and
celebrities hanging out in the
wilderness
hey do you think we're gonna become
friends no
thankfully netflix is bringing more
stand up to the mix in november 2020
heading all the way to germany and the
land down under to source the laughter
november 3rd sees the release of felix
lowbrecht hype
the comedian's debut special hype sees
31 year old lowbrecht commenting on woke
culture
what it's like to get older and fun with
butterfly knives alternately auntie
donna's big old house of fun
is set to arrive on netflix november
11th produced by scott auckerman and ed
helms
it's a six-part sketch comedy
extravaganza coming out of australia
starring the absurdist comedy group
auntie donna hey anzac you've gone
low-res
oh my god how embarrassing as for the
new television offerings netflix has
both old favorites and new seasons
of its original programs arriving in
november 2020. british history buffs
will be thrilled that the crown is
returning for its fourth season on
november 15th
continuing the story of the modern
british monarchy with olivia coleman at
the helm
as queen elizabeth ii however if you're
looking for a soapy binge you'll
definitely want to check out the
entirety of dawson's creek which will
appear on netflix on november 1st
if you want to catch up with ryan
murphy's horror anthology american
horror story
one of its most recent seasons of 1984
will be available to stream on november
13th
and if you're looking for two very
specific seasons of the long-running hit
cbs reality series survivor
you're in luck seasons 20 and 28 of the
stranded island competition will be
available on november 15th
as many people will argue the minute the
clock strikes 12 am on november 1st the
christmas season has officially begun
viewers looking for romance can load up
the netflix original film operation
christmas drop
which follows a congressional aide as
she spends christmas traveling across
the pacific ocean
delivering gifts via parachute to a
series of remote islands
that one lands on netflix on november
5th later in the month on november 13th
subscribers can catch another netflix
original jingle jangle a christmas
journey
the film stars forest whitaker as toy
maker jeronicus jangle
whose apprentice played by keegan
michael key steals his most valuable
invention
it's foolproof you are proof that there
are fools
fools fools fools fool's fools two of
the most highly anticipated netflix
original holiday movies hit the streamer
on november 19th and november 25th the
first the princess switch switched again
it's a sequel to the vanessa hodgins
starring runaway hits the second the
christmas chronicles 2
once again features kurt russell as old
saint nick himself
as autumn turns to winter leaves fall
from the trees providing warmth and
nourishment to the roots below
so too does netflix shed old programs
making way for new growth
tragically november 2020 sees the
culling of netflix's assortment of
jeopardy collections
with its champion run series leaving the
streaming service on november 17th
though ocean's 11 arrives on netflix on
november 1st it and the rest of the
oceans trilogy will leave on november
30th
the addams family sadly bounces on
november 15th
as does the cult classic cgi adventure
9. any reminder of a pre twilight's
taylor lautner will escape the public
consciousness when robert rodriguez's
the adventures of shark boy and lava
girl
bows out at the end of the month shark
knight leaves on november 1st
and 2011 soul surfer will be gone on the
16th
it's a rough month for sharks check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and tv shows are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one